This is 99% invisible. I'm Delaney Hall, filling in for Roman Mars. In 1997, a curator named Catherine Ott was learning her way around the Smithsonian National Museum of American History. She was new to the job, she specialized in medical science, and there was this one storage room in the building where she worked. It's like that classic, what you'd think of as a dark, dusty, sort of scary, mildly, mysterious storage room in a museum. There were drug jars, there was parts of mannequin bodies laying around. But the weirdest thing was. There was this wheelchair that had go-cart wheels. It was completely customized. It had a recarrow
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是Delaney Hall，代班Roman Mars。1997年，一位名叫Catherine Ott的策展人正在熟悉史密森尼国家美国历史博物馆的工作环境。她当时刚入职，专攻医学史，博物馆里有一间她负责的储藏室。那间储藏室就像你想象中博物馆里那种经典的样子：昏暗、积灰、有点吓人，还带着一丝神秘感。里面有药罐，有散落的人体模型部件。但最奇怪的是，有一辆装了卡丁车轮子的轮椅。它经过了彻底的改装，上面装了一个保时捷汽车用的Recaro座椅。但我总是被它绊倒，最后我心想，这到底是个什么东西？于是Catherine Ott开始四处打听，这辆轮椅是从哪儿来的？为什么会被放在储藏室里？而在“城堡”（史密森尼员工对主楼的称呼）里，没人能真正告诉她。没人完全清楚这辆轮椅的主人是谁。它就像篮子里的弃婴一样，被留在了城堡的门口，上面还别着一张字条。
seat that was used in Porsche cars, but I kept tripping over it and finally I'm like, what the heck is this thing? So Catherine Ott started asking around, where did this wheelchair come from? Why is it in storage? And no one at the castle, which is what the staff calls the main Smithsonian building, could really tell her. Nobody completely understood who had owned it. It had been left at the door of the castle with a note pinned to it like an orphan in a basket.
字条上写着，这是一辆属于Ed Roberts的轮椅。我们认为它应该被收藏在史密森尼博物馆。Ed Roberts，我当时还没听说过这个名字。如果你住在美国城市，且平时不用轮椅，你可能不太会注意到大多数路口人行道和街道之间那个小小的斜坡。那只是一个坡道，路缘石上的一个切口。现在全国到处都是。几乎任何有人行道的地方都能见到。
And the note said this was a chair that belonged to Ed Roberts. We think it should be at the Smithsonian. Ed Roberts, I didn't recognize the name, not yet. If you live in an American city and you don't personally use a wheelchair, you probably don't pay much attention to the small slope at most intersections between the sidewalk and the street. It's just a ramp, a cut in the curb. They're all over the country now. Just about any place you find sidewalks.
那是记者Cynthia Gourney。但在60年前，当这辆轮椅的主人Ed Roberts还年轻时，大多数城市路口的人行道尽头都是陡峭的落差。这足以让一个坐轮椅的人在没有帮助的情况下无法到达下一个街区。而关于第一批广泛应用的城市路缘坡道是如何出现的，故事要从一场运动说起。
That's reporter Cynthia Gourney. But 60 years ago, when Ed Roberts, the owner of that wheelchair, was young, the sidewalks at most urban intersections ended with a sharp drop-off. That's enough to stop a person in a wheelchair from reaching the next block without help. And the story of how the first widespread urban curb cuts came to be, it starts with a movement
这场运动要求社会以一种新的方式看待残疾人。Roberts是这场运动的核心人物。数百名帮助他把轮椅拖过华盛顿特区宪法大道的人也是如此，这样它最终才能被史密森尼博物馆收藏。他们坚持认为这是美国历史的一部分。Ed Roberts在旧金山附近的伯林格姆长大。他是四个男孩中的老大，热爱打棒球。但14岁那年，他得了一场高烧，病得很重。几天之内，
that demanded society see disabled people in a new way. And Roberts was central to that movement. And so were the hundreds of people who helped drag his wheelchair up Constitution Avenue right in the middle of Washington, D.C DC so it could end up with the Smithsonian. They insisted it was a piece of American history. Ed Roberts grew up in Berlin game near San Francisco. He was the oldest of four boys and he loved to play baseball. But one day when he was 14 years old he got really sick with a fever. Within a
他就住进了医院。那是Ed的母亲Zona Roberts，她现在98岁了。两天之内，他就被推进了铁肺呼吸机，因为他已经无法自主呼吸了。他患上了小儿麻痹症。这种病严重损害了他的呼吸肌，以至于他必须依靠铁肺才能活下去。现在已经不再生产铁肺了，但在当时，它们是那种全身式的呼吸器，
few days he was in the hospital. That's Zona Roberts, Ed's mom. She's 98 now. And within two days of that, he was in brush to an iron lung because he couldn't breathe any more on his own. It had polio. It had damaged his respiratory muscles so much that he needed the iron lung to stay alive. Iron lungs aren't made anymore, but back in the day they were these full body respirators
将小儿麻痹症幸存者从脖子以下包裹在金属中，通过压力将空气吸入和排出他们的肺部。Ed的小儿麻痹症造成的破坏远不止呼吸功能。他脖子以下瘫痪了。他左手只能动两根手指，仅此而已。他的瘫痪是永久性的。那位告诉Ed父母他们的儿子挺过了高烧的医生，并没有把这当作好消息。
that encased polio survivors in metal up to the neck and pulled air in and out of their lungs. Ed's polio wrecked a lot more than his breathing. It left him paralyzed below the neck. He could move two fingers on his left hand and that was it. His paralysis was permanent. The doctor who told Ed's parents their son had survived his high fever did not present this as good news.
他说，好吧，如果你余生都必须生活在铁肺里，你会作何感想？我想你从来没进去过。我进去过，那不是一种很好的生活方式。为了偶尔逃离铁肺，Ed自学了一种叫“青蛙呼吸法”的技巧。那是深海潜水员的一种窍门，像青蛙一样把氧气吞进肺里。对于那些虚弱的呼吸肌不足以吸入所需氧气的小儿麻痹症幸存者来说，青蛙呼吸法意味着一个人可以短时间离开铁肺。
He said, well, how would you feel if you had to live in an iron lung the rest of your life? I don't imagine you've ever been in one. I've been in one and it's not a very good way to live. In order to escape the iron lung once in a while, Ed taught himself on his own a technique called frog breathing. That's a deep sea divers trick where you gulp oxygen into your lungs the way a frog does. For polio survivors whose weakened breathing muscles weren't strong enough to inhale that needed oxygen, frog breathing met a person could get out of the iron lung for short stretches of time.
就像那样吞咽空气。你吞下它，然后就能呼吸了。他们一直叫他停下来。这对他的身体不好，当然他还是坚持这样做，因为这能让他活下去。Ed决心按照自己的方式活下去。这是他在1989年接受《60分钟》采访时的片段。即使是残疾最严重的人，也很少有人无法掌控自己的生活。问题在于，我们周围的人并不期待我们这样做。想想你自己的生活。
You swallow air like that. You swallow it and then you can breathe and they kept telling him to stop it. That was not good for his body and of course he kept doing it because it kept him alive. And Ed was determined to stay alive on his own terms. Here he is in a 60 minutes interview from 1989. There are very few people, even with the most severe disabilities who can't take control of their own life. The problem is that people around us don't expect this to. Think about your own life.
如果有人照顾你，替你做所有决定，那生活还有什么意义？去做吧。Ed很顽强，但一切都很艰难。他睡觉时需要铁肺，但青蛙呼吸法让他白天可以离开一会儿。所以他坚持上学，每周去一次校园。当Ed离开家时，他的家人负责操作。他们帮助他在一个并非为残疾人建造的世界中穿行。当Ed离开家时，他的家人负责操作。他们帮助他在一个
If you have people taking care of you, making all your decisions, what is in life? Do it. Ed was tenacious, but everything was hard. He needed the iron lung while he was asleep, but the frog breathing let him leave it for a while during the day. So he stayed in school, going to campus once a week. When Ed did leave the house, his family ran the maneuvers. They were helping him navigate a world that wasn't built for a person in a week. When Ed did leave the house, his family ran the maneuvers. They were helping him navigate a
并非为轮椅使用者建造的世界中穿行。Ed的兄弟或父亲会帮他抬上轮椅，把轮椅拖出家门，然后把轮椅抬过路缘石，上下楼梯。或者如果Zona一个人，她就会找陌生人帮忙。我得找人帮我把轮椅抬上楼梯，一个人在后面，一个人在框架上，把它抬上去，或者有时候就只有我一个人。Ed高中毕业后又从当地社区学院毕业，但当他1962年想去伯克利分校时，大学起初拒绝了他，认为他残疾太严重了。而且他能安全住在哪里呢？他每晚仍需使用的铁肺，
world that wasn't built for a person in a wheelchair. Ed's brothers or his dad would help lift him into his chair, drag the chair out of the house, and then lift the chair over curbs and up and down stairs. Or if Zona were alone, she would wrangle strangers. I'd have to get somebody help me get the chair up the stairs so it would be somebody in the back and somebody on the frame and get it up or sometimes it would just be me. Ed graduated from high school then from a local community college but when he wanted to go on to Berkeley in 1962 the university at first said no he was just too disabled. And where could he safely live? The iron lung, which he still used every night,
根本放不进宿舍房间。直到最后，有人建议让他住在校园医院里。一个病房被改造成了Ed和他所有设备的居住空间。这是Ed Roberts，5月2日，录音1，9月15日。在后来的一系列口述历史采访中，Ed回忆了作为伯克利本科生开始生活的情景。
wouldn't fit in a dorm room. Until finally, somebody suggested housing him at the campus hospital. A patient's room remade into a living space for Ed and all his equipment. This is Ed Roberts, five, 2, tape 1, September 15. In a series of oral history interviews, much later, Ed remembered what it was like to start as a Berkeley undergrad.
你还记得你搬进大学的那天吗？记得。那是什么感觉？既兴奋又害怕。护理员会推着Ed去上每一节课，然后Ed会招募一名同学帮他记笔记。我做了一个简短的公告，他上了一节课，通常会找到一个看起来不错的Ed Woolbert。
Do you remember the day you moved in the college? Yeah, I did. What it was like? It was a combination of excitement and scary. An attendant would wheel Ed to each class, and then Ed would recruit a classmate to help him take notes. And I did a quick announcement and he did a class and he would usually find a good look at Ed Woolbert.
他会给那位女士一张复写纸，她在讲座期间记笔记，课后把复写纸副本还给Ed。这真是一种记笔记的方式。当然，还要接触人们并让他们参与进来。所以这些都是小小的批评。Ed学习和阅读得非常多，以至于他用来翻书的口杖开始把他的牙齿顶得变形了。校园官员们看到这个实验奏效了。报纸写了关于Ed的报道。
He'd give the woman a piece of carbon paper, she would take notes during the lecture, and then she'd give the carbon copy back to Ed at the end. It's such a way of taking notes. And of course to beat people and get them evolving. So they're worth all these little critics. Ed did so much studying and reading that the mouth wand he used to turn the pages of books started pushing his teeth out of shape. So campus officials saw this experiment was working. Newspapers wrote stories about Ed.
他妈妈现在还喜欢拿那些标题开玩笑。“无助的残疾人上大学”，这是我们都喜欢的一个。后来，第二个四肢瘫痪的学生搬进了Ed的临时医院宿舍。那是一个年轻小伙子，在跳水事故中瘫痪，起初被告知应该习惯做一个足不出户的人。接着又来了几个，有的住在医院，有的在校外找了住处。消息开始传开了。伯克利发生了一些不同寻常的事情。
His mom still likes to make fun of the headlines. Helpless cripple goes to college, that's one we all love. And then a second quadriplegic student moved into Ed's makeshift hospital dorm. A young man who had been paralyzed in a diving accident and was initially told he should just get used to life as a shut-in. Then a few more arrived, both to live in the hospital and to find lodgings off campus. The word started to spread. Something unusual was going on at Berkeley.
这些学生有着严重且显而易见的残疾。州政府支付特别护理费用，帮他们把轮椅抬上楼梯和教学楼。你不可能忽略校园里这些新面孔。别忘了那是20世纪60年代。Ed去伯克利的那一年，黑人詹姆斯·梅雷迪思（James Meredith）进入了密西西比大学并实现了种族融合。那是史蒂夫·布朗（Steve Brown）的故事。他患有一种遗传综合征，除其他症状外，还会导致骨骼容易骨折。所以他有时会使用轮椅，也是残疾文化研究所的联合创始人。所以60年代是一个充满抗议、改革和变革的时代，你知道有一个非常专业的历史术语，它“弥漫在空气中”。确实弥漫在空气中。对于残疾人来说，它也弥漫在空气中。
These students had profound and visible disabilities. The state paid special attendance to heft their wheelchairs, up staircasescases and intellectual halls. You couldn't miss the new presence on campus. And don't forget this was the 1960s. Ed went to Berkeley at the same year that James Meredith, a black man went to University of Mississippi and integrated it. That's a story in Steve Brown. He has a genetic syndrome that among other things makes his bones break easily. So he's a sometimes wheelchair user and a co-founder of the Institute on Disability Culture. So the 60s were a time of lots of protests and lots of reform and lots of change, and you know there's this very technical historical term, it was in the air. And it was in the air. It was in the air for disabled people too.
那个在校园医院里的临时宿舍，那些房间变成了充满活力和反叛精神的组织者们的总部，比如Ed和Hale Zukas，一个患有脑瘫、通过词汇板和绑在头上的指针进行交流的坚定的人。他们自称为“滚动四肢瘫痪者”（Rolling Quads）。像全国其他几个残疾青年联盟一样，他们开始使用一种新的语言来谈论他们的需求和权利。残疾人拥有公民权利这一激进思想，即受教育权、就业权、受尊重权、真正融入公共生活的权利，
That improvised dorm in the campus hospital, those rooms turned into the headquarters for an exuberant and irreverent group of organizers like Ed and Hale Zuckas, an assertive guy with cerebral palsy who communicated with a word board and a pointer strapped to his head. They called themselves the rolling quads. And like a few other coalitions of disabled young people around the country, they started using a new kind of language to talk about their needs and rights. The radical idea that people with disabilities had civil rights, the right to education, to jobs, to respect, to real inclusion in public life,
这完全契合了60年代和70年代初的革命精神。伯克利的残疾学生在伯克利很有名。那时，那是一个爆炸性的地方。那是Judy Heumann，她小时候在40年代患过小儿麻痹症，从那时起就一直使用轮椅。她是一位年轻的纽约残疾人权利活动家，
this fit right into the revolutionary spirit of the 1960s and early 70s. And the Berkeley disabled students had a Berkeley reputation. At that time, it was an explosive place. That's Judy Human, who had polio as a kid back in the 1940s and has used a wheelchair since then. She was a young New York disability rights agitator
当她搬到伯克利读研究生时。打破这些门是我们的责任，我们玩得很开心，因为在伯克利组织示威比在曼哈顿容易得多。你知道，我们可以召集30到50名轮椅使用者去市政厅。那是一个相当大的数字。注意她说的是“轮椅骑手”（wheelchair riders），像自行车骑手一样。这听起来和“轮椅束缚”（wheelchair bound）感觉不太一样，对吧？来自全国各地的残疾人来到伯克利寻找工作，成为充满活力的残疾人社区的一部分。
when she moved to Berkeley for graduate school. It was our responsibility to break down the doors and we had a lot of fun because it was much easier to organize a demonstration in Berkeley than in Manhattan. You know, so we could get 30 to 50 wheelchair riders to come to City Hall. That's a pretty large number. Notice she said wheelchair riders with a D like bicycle riders. It doesn't really have the same feel as wheelchair bound, right? And disable people from other parts of the country. We're coming to Berkeley to go to to look for work, to be a part of a disability vibrant community.
我立刻被他们和他们所做的事情吸引了。Debbie Kaplan在大学毕业后的一次跳水事故中摔断了脖子。当她决定学习法律时，伯克利录取了她，Ed和“滚动四肢瘫痪者”立刻说，来和我们一起工作吧。我的意思是，对于残疾人社区的人来说，我们紧紧依靠彼此，因为我们对自己的身份都有这种想法，而周围其他人都没有。我的意思是，当时其他所有人都被困在关于残疾的传统思维方式中。
I was instantly attracted to them and what they were doing. Debbie Kaplan broke her neck in a diving accident just after college. When she decided to study law, Berkeley admitted her, and Ed and the rolling quad said, right away, come work with us. I mean, to people in the disability community, we hung on to each other because we all had this idea about who we were and nobody else around us did. I mean, everybody else was stuck in the standard way of thinking about disability back then.
什么？慈善、公共福利，残疾意味着你什么都做不了，意思是，你知道，杰瑞·刘易斯（Jerry Lewis）的电视募捐活动。你知道我们要为你表演一个节目吗？20个小时？全国直播？你知道吗？
What? Charity and public welfare and disability means you can't do anything, meaning, you know, Jerry Lewis Telephone. You know that we're going to do a show for you now? 20 hours? Coast to coast? You know that?
好了。现在让我们看看能不能让外面的人也爱你。好的。杰瑞·刘易斯的电视募捐活动是这位已故喜剧演员为肌肉萎缩症举办的年度马拉松式筹款活动。他在镜头前做鬼脸，请来名人歌手，花大量时间微笑着俯视那些坐在轮椅上、穿着整齐的可爱孩子。新一代残疾人权利活动家对此深恶痛绝。
Okay. Now let's see if we can get the people out there to love you too. All right. The Jerry Lewis Telephone was the late comedian's annual marathon fundraiser for muscular dystrophy. He mugged for the camera and brought in celebrity singers and spent a lot of time smiling down at cute, well-dressed children in wheelchairs. The rising generation of disability rights activists hated it.
嗯，我们每到阵亡将士纪念日周末就会感到畏缩，因为知道所有这些人都在看杰瑞·刘易斯通过极力渲染关于残疾的最可怕的刻板印象来从人们那里榨取钱财，认为残疾是一种比死亡更糟糕的命运，我们应该被怜悯，如果我们做了什么，我们就是勇敢的，但实际上并不是真正的人。我知道我唯一一次在电视上看到残疾人是在那些电视募捐活动中。这是Lawrence Carter-Long。
Well, we just would cringe every memorial day weekend, knowing that all these people were watching Jerry Lewis squeezing money out of people by dramatically playing up the most horrid stereotypes about disability that having a disability is a fate worse than death, that we should be pitted, that if we do anything, we are brave, and yet really not real people. I knew that the only other time I saw disabled people on TV were during those telephones. This is Lawrence Carter Long.
他是残疾人权利与教育辩护基金的通讯主任。Lawrence五岁时，是联合基金慈善机构的典型海报儿童，因为他天生患有脑瘫，而且很可爱。我出现在公交车侧面。我出现在筹款呼吁中，每个人都会
He's communications director for the Disability Rights and Education Defense Fund. When Lawrence was five, he was a literal poster child for the United Fund charity, because he was born with cerebral palsy, and he was cute. I was on the side of buses. I was in fundraising appeals, and everybody would
说，啊，我想，打开支票簿。直到我大一点上大学时，我才想，等一下，这背后的潜台词是什么？潜台词是，嗯，你不想落得像这个可怜的孩子一样，对吧？那就给我们捐点钱。成年后，Lawrence继续研究残疾人在电影、电视以及公众意识中被描绘的方式。非常清楚的是，有一些叙事经常被讲述，你知道，残疾是我们应该害怕的东西，残疾人是怜悯的对象，我记得在1972年，发生了一场争议，
go, ah, I think, open up the checkbooks. It wasn't until I got a little bit older when I was in college, and I thought, wait a minute, what's the subtext of that? And the subtext was, well, you don't want to end up like this poor kid, do you? Then give us some money. As an adult, Lawrence would go on to study the way disabled people were portrayed in the movies, and on television and generally in the public consciousness. What became very clear is there were certain narratives that got told often, you know, that disability was something that we were to be afraid of, that disabled people were objects of pity, and I remember in 1972, there was a controversy
围绕着杰瑞·刘易斯的电视募捐活动，杰瑞·刘易斯说：“楼上的那位（上帝）搞砸了。我想楼上的那位搞砸了，他犯了个错误。我认为他把像我这样的人和所有这些可爱的残疾人放在这里来修复那个错误。”这在我的脑海里敲响了警钟，人们是这样看我的吗？
around the Jerry Lewis telephone, where Jerry Lewis said, the man upstairs goofed. I think the man upstairs goofed, he made a mistake. And I think he put people like myself and all these lovely people with the celebrity phones here to repair that goof. It rang that bell in my mind in terms of, is that what people think of me?
我是一个上帝的错误吗？回到伯克利，“滚动四肢瘫痪者”特别是Ed Roberts，是杰瑞·刘易斯电视募捐活动的一大解毒剂。Ed和女性调情。他在大学里因为在酒吧外小便被捕。他讲关于四肢瘫痪的黑色幽默。比如当医生告诉他他会变成一个植物人时，Ed回答说：“好啊，那我会成为一个洋蓟。”
That I'm one of God's mistakes? Back at Berkeley, the rolling quads and Ed Roberts in particular were one big antidote to the Jerry Lewis telephone. Ed flirted with women. He got arrested in college for peeing outside a bar. He told dark jokes about quadriplegia. Like when a doctor told him he was gonna be a vegetable and Ed replied, fine, I'll be in artichoke.
外表坚硬多刺，内心柔软。一位测试顾问曾宣称Ed非常有攻击性。Ed喜欢复述他的回应：“好吧，如果你脖子以下瘫痪了，你不觉得攻击性会是一种资产吗？”我认为，进入和被包容的本质意味着你必须在某种程度上强行进入这个世界，并说：“我们在这里。”
Tough and prickly on the outside with a tender heart. A testing counselor once pronounced Ed to be very aggressive. Ed liked recounting his response. Well, if you were paralyzed from the neck down, don't you think aggressiveness would be an asset? The nature, I think, of access of being included, meant that you had to, in some ways, force yourself upon the world and say, we're here.
嘿，嘿，嘿，因为全国其他地方的倾向，甚至起初在伯克利这里，都是说：“我们不想看到那个。你会让那些正常人感到不舒服。”但当Ed Roberts在伯克利读研究生时，残疾学生已经明显地、不可否认地成为了社区的一部分，甚至更多，因为有些人正坐着电动轮椅四处穿梭，这种轮椅最初是为了帮助受伤的退伍军人而发明的，并开始
Hey, hey, hey, because the tendency, the programming for the rest of the country, even here in Berkeley at first, was to say, we don't want to see that. You're going to make those normal people uncomfortable. But by the time Ed Roberts was in graduate school at Berkeley, the disabled students were noticeably, unmistakably, part of the community, even more so because some were zipping around in power chairs which had been invented to help wounded veterans, and were starting
更多地向公众提供。Ed在第一次看到另一位四肢瘫痪者试用电动轮椅时，就对它产生了浓厚的兴趣。现在他有了这种附在轮椅上的新型便携式呼吸机。所以即使他晚上仍然使用铁肺，他也可以离开它更长时间了。而且还有一个女孩。
to be more available to the general public. Ed got really interested in power chairs when he first watched another quadriplegic tri-1 out. And now he had one of these new portable ventilators that attached to his wheelchair. So even though he still used the iron lung at night, he could stay away from it for a lot longer. And there was a girl.
我坠入爱河了。像许多人一样。我们也这样做。让我的护理员推着我的轮椅和我的女朋友一起到处走，变得极其不方便。这是一个我不需要的额外的人，为了更亲密。有了电动轮椅，像Ed这样的人在某些事情上仍然需要护理员。但不是为了移动，不是为了去约会。我一天就学会了驾驶电动轮椅。
I fell in love. Like many people do. We do that as well. And it became ridiculously inconvenient to have my attendant pushing me around in my wheelchair with my girlfriend. It was an extra person that I didn't need to be more intimate. With a power chair, a person like Ed would still need an attendant for some things. Not for locomotion though, not to go on a date. I learned how to drive a power wheelchair in one day.
我动力十足。拥有它在很多方面改变了我对自己残疾的看法。她跳到我的膝盖上，我们一起驶向夕阳，或者驶向最近的汽车旅馆。但想想看。十多年来，你之所以能四处走动，是因为有人在你身后推着你的轮椅。
I was so motivated. It had changed in many ways my perception of my disability to have myself. And she jumped on my lap and rewrote off into the sunset or to the closest motel. But think about this. For more than a decade, you've been able to get around because somebody's behind you pushing your chair.
现在你靠自己的力量了。十多年来，你之所以能四处走动，是因为有人在你身后推着你的轮椅。现在你靠自己的力量了。你可以把那个轮椅护理员甩在身后。但你仍然必须应对路缘石。如果你想过马路，而没有路缘坡道，六英寸的落差简直就像珠穆朗玛峰。六英寸带来了天壤之别。如果你无法越过那个路缘石。这些人只有在能越过路上的路缘落差后，才能独立滚动。而且
And now you're under your own power. More than a decade, you've been able to get around because somebody's behind you pushing your chair. And now you're under your own power. You get to leave that wheelchair attendant behind. But you still have to contend with curbs. If you're trying to get across the street, and there are no curb cuts, six inches might as well be Mount Everest. Six inches makes all the difference in the world. If you can't get over that curb. These guys could only roll independently once they could get over the curb drop-offs on the way. And
是的，他们可以去寻找车道，但这对于坐轮椅的人来说很危险。车道会把你直接送进车流中。标记路口的全部意义在于它告诉你这里是安全过马路的地方。电动轮椅骑手，实际上所有的轮椅骑手，都需要我们现在所说的路缘坡道。那些在拐角处的斜坡，使得在人行道和街道之间滚动变得容易。
yeah, they could go hunt for a driveway, but that's dangerous for somebody in a wheelchair. A driveway sends you right out into traffic. The whole point of a marked intersection is that it shows you this is where it's safe to cross. The power-chair riders, actually all the wheelchair riders, needed what we now call curb cuts. Those slopes at the corners that make it easy to roll between sidewalk and street.
在这里，如果能告诉你路缘坡道的发明者是谁就好了。那个第一个想到切出小斜坡，让人可以滚进路口而不是必须走下路缘石的聪明人。但没人知道那是谁。我们只知道它们当时还不是标准配置，大多数路口都没有，伯克利没有，任何地方都没有。
And here's where it would be great to be able to tell you about the inventor of the curb cut. The clever person who first thought of cutting little ramps so people could roll into intersections instead of having to step off curves. But nobody knows who that was. All we know is that they were not a standard feature yet and most intersections, not in Berkeley, not anywhere.
早在40年代和50年代，全国有几个社区的人们曾试图让部分建筑环境变得更易进入。例如，伊利诺伊州有一位教练与残疾士兵一起工作，他不断纠缠伊利诺伊大学不情愿的官员。比如，“真为你们感到羞耻，这些男人和女人是为了我们而受伤的”，直到最后学校在其最重要的校园里建立了一个康复和教育项目，有轮椅运动和进入建筑物的木坡道。但到了60年代末和70年代，像“滚动四肢瘫痪者”这样新一代年轻残疾活动家，他们不会等待偶尔开明的大学教练。他们要求。他们坚持。
Back in the 1940s and 50s, there were a few communities across the country where people had tried to make parts of the built environment more accessible. For example, there was a coach in Illinois working with disabled soldiers who badgered reluctant officials at the University of Illinois. Like, shame on you, these men and women were injured fighting for us until finally the school set up a rehab and education program on its most important campus, with wheelchair sports and wood ramps into buildings. But by the late 1960s and 70s, this new wave of young disabled activists like the rolling quads, they weren't going to wait around for the occasional enlightened college coach. They demanded. They were insistent.
他们没有等待许可。你仍然会听到这些关于“滚动四肢瘫痪者”在午夜进行突击行动的故事，坐着轮椅的人和他们的护理员使用大锤或手提钻砸开路缘石，建造他们自己的坡道，并强迫城市采取行动。但关于有午夜突击队员的故事有点夸张了。“夸张了，”他说。那是Eric Dibner。70年代初，他是伯克利的一名残疾学生护理员，算是“滚动四肢瘫痪者”的同路人。是的，他说，也许他们中有些人不耐烦了。也许他们确实自己浇筑了一些坡道。我们买了一两袋混凝土，混合好，带到那些最能
They didn't wait for permission. You still hear these stories about the rolling quads going out on commando raids at midnight, guys in wheelchairs with their attendants using sledgehammers or jackhammers to bust up curbs, build their own ramps, and force the city into action. But the story that there were midnight commandos is a little bit exaggerated. Exaggerated, he said. That's Eric Dibner. In the early 1970s, he was a disabled student's attendant at Berkeley, sort of a rolling quad's fellow traveler. And yeah, he says, maybe a few of them got impatient. Maybe they did go poor a few ramps themselves. We got a bag or two of concrete and mixed it up and took it to the corners that would most
缓解路线的拐角处。所以这种情况发生在不到六个拐角处。这些行动中有任何是在午夜进行的吗？是的，它们都是在夜幕掩护下完成的。这可能违反了法律，对吧？所以你可以称它们为突击行动，或者其他什么。那些突击行动从未大规模发生过。相反，“滚动四肢瘫痪者”取得的大部分进展稍微更官僚一些，稍微更像真正的变革通常是如何实现的。
ease the route. So that occurred on I'd say less than half a dozen corners. Did any of these runs occur at midnight? Yes, they were all done in the cloak of darkness. It may have been against the law, right? And so you can call them commando raids, or whatever. Those commando raids never happened on a grand scale. Instead, most of the progress made by the rolling quads was a little more bureauc Instead, most of the progress made by the rolling quads was a little more bureaucratic, a little more how real change often gets made.
1971年的一天，“滚动四肢瘫痪者”成群结队地出现在伯克利市议会。Ed Roberts，当时已经是政治学研究生，Hale Zukas，那个带着指针和词汇板、学会了俄语并即将完成数学学位的家伙，以及他们所有残疾和非残疾的朋友。当你想象这个场景时，记住伯克利的议会厅并不大。看到一大群人坐着轮椅
One day, in 1971, the rolling quads show up at the Berkeley City Council in a posse. Ed Roberts, who by now is a polypsych grad student, hailszukus, the guy with a pointer and the wordboard who's learned Russian and is finishing a math degree, and all their friends disabled and not. When you picture this, remember that Berkeley's council chambers are not very big. We really were kind of stunned to see a whole lot of people in wheelchairs
滚进议会会议，说他们想要在伯克利的每个街角都有路缘坡道，因为他们需要四处走动，而且他们想能够自己四处走动，我们真的感到相当震惊。那是Lonnie Hancock，她曾是伯克利市议会议员，后来担任过市长，之后加入了加州州议会。据我记得，我们在舞台上，所以我们被抬高了，而坐轮椅的人在我们下面，
wheeling into the council meeting and saying that they wanted to have curb cuts on every street corner in Berkeley because they needed to get around and they want to be able to get around by themselves. That's Lonnie Hancock who was a Berkeley City Council member and then the city's mayor before joining the California State Legislature. We were on a stage, as I remember, so we were elevated, and the people in wheelchairs were down below us,
抬头看着我们，看着他们的脸，意识到他们来到这里所付出的努力，而且他们要求的是据我们所知在地球上从未做过的事情，这是一种压倒性的感觉，但意识到这是我们可以做、应该做并且会做的事情。于是他们实施了世界上第一个广泛的路缘坡道计划。市议会会议记录，1971年9月28日。
looking up at us, and just looking into their faces, and realizing the effort that it took for them to be there, and that they were requesting something that had never been done to our knowledge anywhere on earth was an overwhelming sensation but realizing that it's something that we could do and should do and would do. And so they did the world's first widespread curb cuts program. City Council minutes September 28th 1971.
宣布这是城市的政策，街道和人行道的设计和建造应旨在促进残疾人在主要商业区域内的通行。在全市15个指定的拐角处立即修建路缘坡道。该动议获得一致通过。到了70年代中期，残疾人权利运动正在成长和蔓延。具有“滚动四肢瘫痪者”那种态度的团体在全国甚至全世界成倍增加。在接下来的二十年里，有一个形容词对这场新运动至关重要：独立。对于这场运动中的每个人来说，物理修复清单雄心勃勃，那些必须在建筑环境中改变以使真正的独立成为可能的事情。
Declaring it to be the policy of the city, that streets and sidewalks be designed and constructed to facilitate circulation by handicap persons within major commercial areas. That curb cuts be made immediately at 15 specified corners throughout the city. The motion carried unanimously. By the mid 1970s, the disability rights movement was growing and spreading. Groups with a rolling quad sort of attitude were multiplying around the country and even world. And one adjective was pretty much key to the new movement over the next two decades. Independent. And for everybody in this crusade, the physical fixes list was ambitious, things that had to change in the built environment to make real independence possible.
不仅仅是路缘坡道，还有公交车上的轮椅升降机、楼梯旁的坡道、公共建筑中按钮可及的电梯和无障碍卫生间。服务柜台，低到足以让坐轮椅的人能够面对面地得到服务，受到尊重，而不是被从高处俯视。于是他们开始工作。他们很累，很脏，很不舒服，但他们的精神高涨。旧金山H.E.W.总部现在已经是第三天了，125名残疾人承诺将静坐抗议持续到明天晚上。
Not just curb cuts, wheelchair lifts on buses, ramps alongside staircases, elevators with reachable buttons in public buildings and accessible bathrooms. Service counters, low enough to let a person in a wheelchair be attended to face to face, respectfully, not peered down at from way on high. So they got to work. They're tired, they're grubby, they're uncomfortable, but their spirits are soaring. The Senate San Francisco's H.E.W. headquarters now is in its third day, and 125 disabled and handicapped are pledging to continue the sit-in through tomorrow night.
不再长了。1977年，残疾人权利抗议者同时冲击了11个城市的联邦办公大楼。他们敦促政府对长期被忽视的保护所有接受联邦资金设施中残疾人的规则采取行动。旧金山的抗议活动演变成了一场为期一个月的静坐，新闻持续报道着坐轮椅的人们，
It's not longer. In 1977, disability rights protesters hit federal office buildings in 11 cities at once. They were pushing the government to act on long neglected rules protecting the disabled in all facilities taking federal money. The San Francisco protests turned into a month-long sit-in with steady news coverage of people in wheelchairs,
互相照顾，拒绝离开。这支坐轮椅的占领军没有表现出任何遵守法律的迹象。静坐奏效了，这些成年残疾示威者对怜悯不感兴趣的形象不断积累。1980年，丹佛的残疾人举行抗议，要求修建路缘坡道。他们已经封锁了交通，直到城市交通官员承诺在所有公交车上安装轮椅升降机。现在，几个坐着自己轮椅的人俯身让摄影师拍摄他们猛击
taking care of each other and refusing to leave. The occupation army in wheelchairs shows no signs of calling the law. The sit-in worked, and these images of the grown-up disability demonstrator uninterested in pity kept accumulating. 1980, disabled people in Denver stage a protest demanding curb cuts. They've already blocked traffic until city transit officials promised to put in wheelchair lifts on all the buses. Now a couple guys in their own wheelchairs lean over for the photographers to whack down
混凝土路缘石。他们手里拿着大锤。1988年。加劳德特大学（国家聋人大学）的董事会试图任命一位像迄今为止其他所有人一样不是聋人的校长。愤怒的学生抵制课程并关闭了校园，直到他们的候选人成为该校第一位聋人校长。1990年，当全面的《美国残疾人法案》（ADA）在众议院陷入僵局时，
at concrete curbs. They're holding sledgehammers. 1988. Trustees at Gallaudet, the National University for the Deaf, try to appoint a president who, like every other so far, is not deaf. Angry students boycott classes and shut down the campus until their candidate becomes the college's first deaf president. And in 1990, when the sweeping Americans with Disabilities Act gets hung up in the House of
国会大厦前的残疾示威者离开轮椅，爬上大理石台阶，以确保该法案获得通过。无论你转到电视的哪个频道，那都是你看到的画面，数百万美国人看到的是残疾人爬上美国国会大厦的台阶，不是请求，不是乞求，而是要求，要求成为社会的一部分。勇敢地走向每个人以前去过的地方。ADA并不是第一部旨在消除残疾人障碍的联邦立法，但其影响范围是前所未有的。它强制要求残疾人在
Representatives, disabled demonstrators in front of the Capitol building leave their wheelchairs and crawl up the marble steps to make sure that that bill gets through. Wherever you turned on the television, that was the image that you saw that millions of Americans saw were disabled people crawling up the stairs of the United States Capitol, not asking, not begging, demanding, demanding to be a part of society. Holy going where everyone else had gone before. The ADA wasn't the first federal legislation designed to remove barriers for disabled people, but its reach was unprecedented. It mandated access and accommodation for the disabled in
所有对公众开放的地方、企业、住宿、交通、就业方面获得进入权和便利设施。当然，它也有限定条件。ADA只要求对雇主和建筑商等来说是“合理的”。关于“合理”这个词有很多争论。但在1990年的法案签署仪式上，乔治·H·W·布什总统动情地谈到了柏林墙的倒塌，那堵墙曾将共产主义东德与西方隔开。注意他提到的工具。
all places open to the public, businesses, lodgings, transportation, employment. And it had qualifiers, to be sure. The ADA required only what was, quote, unquote, reasonable for employers and builders and so on. And there was a lot of argument about that word reasonable. But at the Bill signing ceremony in 1990, President George H.W. Bush spoke with a motion about the recent fall of the Berlin Wall, which had divided communist East Germany from the West. Note the tool he mentions.
现在我签署这项立法，它对另一堵墙挥下了大锤。这堵墙几十年来一直将残疾美国人与他们能瞥见却无法触及的自由隔离开来。我们再次欢呼，因为这道障碍倒塌了，我们共同宣称：我们不会接受，我们不会原谅，我们不会容忍美国的歧视。Ed Roberts，那个你看到的伯克利官员曾认为对他们的大学来说太残疾的人，完成了他的硕士学位，在校园任教，并共同创立了独立生活中心，这是一个成为世界各地数百个类似机构典范的残疾人服务组织。
And now I sign legislation, which takes a sledgehammer to another wall. One which has for too many generations separated Americans with disabilities from the freedom they could glimpse but not grasp. And once again we rejoice as this barrier falls for claiming together we will not accept, we will not excuse, we will not tolerate discrimination in America. Ed Roberts, the guy you see Berkeley officials once thought was too crippled for their university, finished his master's degree, taught on campus, and co-founded the Center for Independent Living, a disability service organization that became a model for hundreds of others around the world.
他还结婚、生子、离婚、获得了麦克阿瑟天才奖，并管理了近十年的整个加州州立康复服务部。当心脏病发作夺走他的生命时，他56岁，是国际上残疾人独立运动的知名人物。我惊呆了！Julia Sainn在北卡罗来纳州夏洛特市经营着“残疾人权利与资源”组织。它是基于独立生活中心模式的项目之一。1995年，Julia参加了在华盛顿特区举行的全国独立生活委员会年度游行和会议。Ed在几周前去世了，现在日程上安排了一场为他举行的特别纪念活动。我们将沿着主街游行到国会大厦。
He also married, fathered a son, divorced, won a MacArthur Genius Grant, and for nearly a decade ran the whole California State Department of Rehabilitation Services. He was 56, an international name and independence for the disabled, when a heart attack killed him. I was stunned! Julius Sainn runs Disability Rights and Resources in Charlotte, North Carolina. It's one of those programs based on the Center for Independent Living Model. And in 1995, Julia was at the annual March and Meeting of the National Council for Independent Living in Washington, DC. Ed had died a few weeks earlier, and a special memorial for him was now on the schedule. We were going to be marching down the main streets to the Capitol.
他们打算把Ed的轮椅放在游行队伍的最前面。游行者跟随那辆空轮椅，它由Ed的护理员拖着，直到他们到达参议院办公大楼。进入大楼后，演讲者们站起来纪念Ed的一生和遗产。来自爱荷华州的参议员Tom Harkin发表了悼词，他说，你知道，当马丁·路德·金去世时，他们为他建造了雕像以纪念他。但是Ed Roberts，Harkin说，有一个……在过去的几年里，美国军方一直在致力于建造一座19世纪建造的建筑。在19世纪，美国军方一直在致力于
They were going to put Ed's wheelchair at the front of the march. The marchers followed the empty wheelchair, which was being dragged along by Ed's attendant until they reached the Senate office building. And then once inside, speakers got up to honor Ed's life and legacy. And Senator Tom Harkin from Iowa gave the eulogy and he said you know when Martin Luther King, Jr. passed, they built statues to him in honor of him. But Ed Roberts Harkin said, there was a In the last few years, the American military has been working in the construction of a building that was built in the 19th century. In the 19th century, the American military has been working
在19世纪。美国军方一直在致力于19世纪。美国军方一直在致力于19世纪。美国军方一直在致力于19世纪。美国军方一直在致力于19世纪。美国军方一直在致力于19世纪。美国军方一直在致力于……后来，在游行者回家或回到酒店后，Ed Roberts的护理员把轮椅推到了剩下的路程，并把它留在了
in the 19th century. The American military has been working in the 19th century. The American military has been working in the 19th century. The American military has been working in the 19th century. The American military has been working And sometime later, after the marchers had gone home or back to their hotels, Ed Roberts attendant pushed the wheelchair the rest of the way and left it on the front steps of
史密森尼博物馆的前台阶上。这把椅子对我来说很美。那是史密森尼国家美国历史博物馆的策展人Catherine Ott。就是她在储藏室里发现了Ed的轮椅。他的椅子现在仍然在史密森尼的网站上永久展出。它到处都是磕碰和凹痕，留下了他的印记。后面有一个很大的电池笼。
the Smithsonian. The chair is beautiful to me. That's Catherine Ott, the curator at the Smithsonian National Museum of American History. She's the one who found Ed's wheelchair in the storage room. His chair now remains on permanent display on the Smithsonian's website. It's all banged and dinged and the imprint of him. There's a big battery cage in the back.
它经过了彻底的改装。他有一个保险杠贴纸，上面有自由女神像，用大字母写着“是的，是的，感叹号”。但把Ed的轮椅放在史密森尼博物馆并不意味着现在一切都好了，正如残疾人社区的任何人都会告诉你的那样。每一个坏掉的公交车轮椅升降机，每一个暂时无法使用的地铁电梯，每一个不愿搭载轮椅的Uber司机，每一个打开的井盖或挡住人行道的汽车。大部分纽约市地铁系统，城市领导人多年前决定它太复杂而无法完全无障碍化，建筑环境
It's all customized. He has a bumper sticker with a statue of liberty on it with big letters, yes yes exclamation point. But having Ed's wheelchair at the Smithsonian does not mean everything is now okay as anybody in the disability community will tell you. Every broken bus wheelchair lift, every temporarily out of function subway elevator, every Uber driver who won't take a wheelchair, every open manhole cover or car blocking the sidewalk. Most of the New York City subway system, which city leaders years ago decided was just too complicated to make fully accessible, the built environment
仍然到处都是障碍。路缘坡道现在很常见，但并非每个路口都有，即使在伯克利也是如此。当谈到态度、偏见以及关于残疾人能做什么、实现什么和享受什么的假设时。我们还没有实现完全的包容。我们总的来说已经设法让人们更容易进入建筑物。
is still littered with barriers. Curb cuts are common now, but they're not at every intersection, even in Berkeley. And when it comes to attitudes and prejudice, and assumptions about what people with disabilities can do and achieve and enjoy. We've not yet accomplished full inclusion. We have managed to make it easier by and large for people to get into the building.
但我们是否做了让人们更容易接受教育的工作？为了不仅有一份工作，而且有一份事业，这些东西对许多人来说还不存在。即使在伯克利。但当你走进Lawrence的办公室时，你会感受到这一点。它位于一座名为“Ed Roberts园区”的建筑内，那栋楼里实际上还有大约十几家其他残疾人权利组织。这个地方横跨伯克利的一整个街区。而且关于它的每一件事都是为所有人使用而设计的。
But have we done the work that's going to make it easier for them to get the education? For again, to not only have a job, but have a career, those things don't yet exist for many people. Even in Berkeley. But here's what hits you when you go into Lawrence's office. It's in a building called the Ed Roberts Campus, and there are actually about a dozen other disability rights organizations in that building too. The place sprawls over an entire block in Berkeley. And every single thing about it is designed for everybody to use.
在内部，像一件伟大的庆祝艺术品一样，是这个巨大的橙色螺旋坡道。它有两层楼高。这是在一楼和二楼之间移动的方式之一，坡道周围的弧形墙上挂满了多年来示威活动的巨幅照片。所以如果你在听这个节目时正在走路，并且碰巧到达了一个路口，
Inside, like a great celebratory piece of art is this huge orange spiraling ramp. It's two stories high. It's one of the ways to move between the first and second floors and all around the ramp the curved walls are lined with giant photos of demonstrations over the years. So if you're listening to this wall walking and you happen to reach an intersection
那里有一个路缘坡道，也许是一个有凸起的坡道，让盲人可以用手杖感觉到人行道在哪里结束，街道在哪里开始。你可能会停顿一下。我认为人们能意识到的最重要的事情是，通过注意到它，停下来，暂停，下次你走在街上，下次你尝试过马路时多加注意。如果可以的话，说声小小的谢谢。路缘坡道不仅对轮椅骑手有帮助，对推婴儿车和购物车的人、使用助行器的老年人、骑自行车的人也有帮助。这种现象被称为
that's got a curb cut, maybe a bumpy one that lets blind people feel by cane where the sidewalk ends and the street begins. You might hold up for just a second. The most important thing I think people can realize is that by noting it, stopping, pausing, paying attention the next time you walk down the street, the next time you try to cross the street. Say a little thank you if you will. Curb cuts haven't just been helpful for wheelchair riders but also for people pushing strollers and shopping carts for elderly people who use walkers for bicyclists. And this phenomenon has come to be known
“路缘坡道效应”。Roman Mars稍后会回来与本故事的记者Cynthia Gourney讨论这个问题。所以过去几周我因为RadioTopia东海岸巡演而不在城里，这就是为什么Delaney代班主持。但我确实及时赶回来，把我们这个故事的记者Cynthia Gourney请进演播室，多聊聊路缘坡道。
as the curb cut effect. Roman Mars will be back to talk with reporter Cynthia Gourney about it right after this. So I was out of town the last couple of weeks on the Radio Topia East Coast tour, which is why Delaney filled in from his host. But I did get back in time to pull Cynthia Gourney, our reporter on this story, into the studio to talk a little bit more about curb cuts,
即路缘坡效应。罗曼·马尔斯稍后将回来与记者辛西娅·古尔尼讨论这个话题。过去几周我因为参加Radio Topia东海岸巡演而不在城里，所以德莱尼代班主持。但我确实及时赶了回来，把这篇报道的记者辛西娅·古尔尼请进演播室，进一步聊聊路缘坡的话题。
and this newish idea that you'll sometimes hear about from disability leaders and designers that's called the curb cut effect. So let's just start with the idea. What is the curb cut effect? The term gets used to describe a fix that is made to help a particular disadvantaged group of people. In this case, for example, putting ramps into sidewalk curbs so that people who roll because they have to can get across the street safely at an intersection. But it's got much wider applications because it turns out that there are a lot of these fixes you do that end up having helpful ramifications for a huge group of people. The GI bill, for example,
还有这个残障领袖和设计师有时会提到的新颖理念，叫做“路缘坡效应”。让我们从这个概念开始。什么是路缘坡效应？这个术语被用来描述一种为了帮助特定弱势群体而做出的改进。例如，在这个案例中，在人行道边缘设置坡道，以便那些必须坐轮椅的人能在十字路口安全过马路。但它的应用范围要广泛得多，因为事实证明，你所做的许多这类改进，最终会对一大群人产生有益的影响。例如，《退伍军人权利法案》（GI Bill），
after World War II, designed specifically to help veterans, ends up helping an enormous wide ranging population in the United States, the home building industry, you know, entire suburban communities, etc. And so who's the first person to apply the curb cut metaphor to this idea? Nobody knows who came up with the term, the curb cut effect. At least, let me rephrase that. I don't know who came up with the term.
在二战后专门为帮助退伍军人而设计，最终却帮助了美国一个极其庞大且广泛的群体，包括房屋建筑业、整个郊区社区等等。那么，谁是第一个将“路缘坡”隐喻应用到这个想法上的人呢？没人知道是谁提出了“路缘坡效应”这个词。至少，让我换个说法。我不知道是谁提出了这个词。
Somebody out there surely knows. I was not able to find out. The idea, however, has been around for quite some time. And the most interesting example of recent times that I learned about came from Steve Brown, the disability historian we heard from earlier. Steve told me that at one point recently, while he was doing a radio program about his work
肯定有人知道。但我没能查到。然而，这个想法已经存在很长一段时间了。我所了解到的最近最有趣的例子来自史蒂夫·布朗（Steve Brown），就是我们之前听到的那位残障历史学家。史蒂夫告诉我，最近有一次，当他正在做一个关于他工作的广播节目时，
and disability history, he got a phone call from his own parents who said, well, Steve, that was all very interesting. You were good on the show, but don't you remember that back in Kalamazoo Michigan where you grew up, by the way, we had some curb cuts and Steve said, what? And it turned out that in the 1940s in Kalamazoo, a disabled or injured veteran had gotten so fed up watching other disabled vets struggling up and down the curbs in Kalamazoo. Kalamazoo turns out, apparently, at least at that time, to have extremely high, unusually
关于残障历史，他接到了他父母的电话，他们说：“嗯，史蒂夫，那很有趣。你在节目里表现得很好，但你不记得在你长大的密歇根州卡拉马祖，顺便说一下，我们有一些路缘坡吗？”史蒂夫说：“什么？”结果发现，在20世纪40年代的卡拉马祖，一位残疾或受伤的退伍军人看到其他残疾退伍军人在卡拉马祖的路缘上挣扎，感到非常厌烦。事实证明，卡拉马祖当时的路缘非常高，
high curbs because of river flooding. And this guy talked the city officials into just in a very few corners downtown cutting ramps into the curbs. They did it. People started using it and they got so interested in what was happening that they decided to study it somewhat formally and see what effect it was having. And so Steve told me the officials commissioned a report. So it said that the curb ramps not only helped people in wheelchairs and people who use
因为河流洪水的原因，路缘异常高。这个人说服了市政官员，在市中心的几个角落切开了坡道。他们照做了。人们开始使用它，他们对发生的事情非常感兴趣，以至于决定对其进行某种正式的研究，看看它产生了什么影响。所以史蒂夫告诉我，官员们委托了一份报告。报告说，路缘坡不仅帮助了坐轮椅的人和使用
the crutches but women and did say women, pushing strollers and delivery men with their deliveries and bicyclists, and then it kind of ended with something like it was creating freedom of movement for everybody. And it turns out there are lots of examples of this that were devised for people who had certain disadvantages, but really benefit all of us. Okay, you're in a really noisy bar. You're watching the basketball game. You're following it with the captions.
拐杖的人，还帮助了推婴儿车的妇女、送货员和骑自行车的人，最后它以类似“它为每个人创造了行动自由”的话语结束。事实证明，有很多这样的例子，它们最初是为有特定劣势的人设计的，但实际上造福了我们所有人。好吧，你在一个非常嘈杂的酒吧里。你在看篮球比赛。你正在通过字幕关注比赛。
You're experiencing the curb cut effect. You're trying to get into a building. Your hands are full of packages. You use the special electronic button or the button that you can just hit with your hip. You've just used a thing that was made for somebody who can't push a door or in the earlier example, somebody who can't here. We run into examples like this all the time without being aware of it. And in fact, when I started working on this story, whenever I would say to people, curb cuts, they would generally, especially if they were under the age of about 60 and
你正在体验路缘坡效应。你正试图进入一栋大楼。你的手里拿满了包裹。你使用了那个特殊的电子按钮，或者可以用臀部按下的按钮。你刚刚使用了一个为那些无法推门的人，或者在之前的例子中，为那些无法听见的人制造的东西。我们一直都在遇到这样的例子，却并没有意识到。事实上，当我开始写这个故事时，每当我对人们说“路缘坡”时，他们通常会，特别是如果他们不到60岁，并且
had not been around Berkeley when the stuff I'm talking about was happening, they would say, oh, you mean those things that are in the sidewalk so you can put your rollie bag or your stroller more easily? So you can get those off the curb. They thought it was meant for them. That's correct. And not for people in Surrey. That's correct. What was the strangest, most unexpected curb cut effect that you found in your research? So the football huddle turns out to have been invented at Gallaudet University, the National University of the Deaf for students who couldn't hear. Because Gallaudet and the late 1800s, early 1900s, we had a football team and they had to figure
没有在伯克利经历过我所说的那些事情，他们会说：“哦，你是说人行道上那些东西，这样你就可以更容易地放你的行李箱或婴儿车吗？这样你就可以把它们从路缘上弄下来。”他们以为那是为他们准备的。没错。而不是为坐轮椅的人准备的。没错。你在研究中发现的最奇怪、最出乎意料的路缘坡效应是什么？事实证明，橄榄球的“聚拢战术”（huddle）是由聋人国立大学加劳德特大学（Gallaudet University）为听不见的学生发明的。因为加劳德特大学在19世纪末、20世纪初有一支橄榄球队，他们必须想出
out a way to communicate with each other. So they got in a huddle and we're signing to each other. And therefore, we can't the huddle. So it's true. It's weird to me, that's a true. It's true. Look it up. So I looked it up.
一种相互交流的方式。所以他们聚在一起，用手语交流。因此，我们不能……聚拢战术。所以这是真的。对我来说这很奇怪，这是真的。这是真的。去查一下。所以我查了一下。
It is true. They were signing because they were playing other deaf teams, and they got into a huddle because they didn't want the other deaf teams to be able to read their signs. So now of course, every team in the NFL uses the football huddle. That makes so much sense. I mean, I wouldn't have thought of that because across a field, you could talk openly for if you had hearing teams, and they couldn't hear you, you would be fine. Exactly.
这是真的。他们当时在用手语，因为他们在和其他聋人球队比赛，他们聚在一起是因为他们不想让其他聋人球队读懂他们的手语。所以现在，当然，NFL的每支球队都使用橄榄球聚拢战术。这太有道理了。我的意思是，我不会想到这一点，因为在球场上，如果你有听力正常的球队，你可以公开交谈，他们听不见你，你也会没事的。完全正确。
That's amazing. Yeah. So this is connected to a bigger idea that I think a lot of designers, and maybe a lot of other people know called universal design. So how is this all connected? Well, the person who is generally cited as the father of universal design, although it's not clear that he actually
太神奇了。是的。所以这与一个我认为许多设计师，也许还有许多其他人知道的更大的想法有关，叫做“通用设计”。那么这一切是如何联系在一起的呢？嗯，通常被认为是通用设计之父的人，尽管不清楚他是否真的
invented that term. He's deceased now was an architect named Ron Mace out of North Carolina. He himself was a wheelchair user. And he did a lot of very influential writing. The general message being, look, we shouldn't be thinking about just people in wheelchairs or just people who can't see or hear when we design. We should be thinking about designs that work for everybody regardless of their mobility,
发明了这个词。他现在已经去世了，是一位来自北卡罗来纳州的建筑师，名叫罗恩·梅斯（Ron Mace）。他本人就是轮椅使用者。他写了很多非常有影响力的文章。总的信息是：看，我们在设计时，不应该只考虑坐轮椅的人，或者只考虑看不见或听不见的人。我们应该考虑对每个人都有效的设计，无论他们的行动能力如何，
their ability to see, their ability to hear, their age, and there's among architects who are advocates of universal design, there's a set of seven principles, which are too elaborate, to enumerate here, but they're very straightforward. They're like things should be simple. They should be easy to use. They should be widely straightforward. They're like things should be simple. They should be easy to use. They should be widely accessible. They should use the best available materials. And so the curb cut has turned out to be a classic example of universal design
他们的视觉能力、听觉能力、年龄如何。在支持通用设计的建筑师中，有一套七项原则，这里太复杂无法一一列举，但它们非常直观。它们就像：事物应该是简单的。它们应该是易于使用的。它们应该是广泛可及的。它们应该使用最好的可用材料。所以路缘坡已经成为通用设计的一个经典例子，
because anybody who rolls uses it. Right. Mostly I think that people think of universal design in the physical space with like nice script handles for people who maybe are arthritic and curb cuts and things. But the next frontier of universal design is in the virtual space because the internet is a place where all of us are living more and more of our lives, more of our time. How is universal design being applied to the virtual worlds? Yeah.
因为任何滚动的人都会使用它。对。我想大多数人认为通用设计是在物理空间中，比如为有关节炎的人准备的漂亮把手和路缘坡之类的东西。但通用设计的下一个前沿是在虚拟空间，因为互联网是我们所有人生活越来越多、花费时间越来越多的地方。通用设计是如何应用于虚拟世界的？是的。
Aside from the football huddle start being started for the deaf, my second favorite phrase in all of this reporting was electronic curb cuts. Wow. Which is the term that people who work in information technology are now using to talk about ways to make that technology accessible, available to people who can't see, can't hear, can't use a mouse in the old days, can't type on a keyboard. And Debbie Kaplan, the person who had originally been involved in the Center for Independent Living that we met earlier in the program, does this.
除了橄榄球聚拢战术是为聋人开始的之外，我在所有这些报道中第二喜欢的短语是“电子路缘坡”。哇。这是信息技术领域的人们现在用来谈论如何使技术变得可访问、可供那些看不见、听不见、在过去无法使用鼠标、无法在键盘上打字的人使用的方法的术语。黛比·卡普兰（Debbie Kaplan），我们之前在节目中见过的最初参与独立生活中心的人，就在做这件事。
This is her specialty now. She works on accessibility of technology, information technology, i.e. electronic curb cuts. You know, those of us who fought for accessibility of the built environment, when we realized that the electronic environment was getting built all around and becoming more and more a part of daily life, we realized that we needed to get involved quickly. And how did they get involved? I think that some of the earliest problems that they wanted to address were how do you
这是她现在的专长。她致力于技术、信息技术的可访问性，即电子路缘坡。你知道，我们这些为建筑环境的可访问性而奋斗的人，当我们意识到电子环境正在被全面构建并日益成为日常生活的一部分时，我们意识到我们需要迅速参与进来。他们是如何参与进来的？我认为他们想要解决的最早的一些问题是：你如何
make computer information available to people who cannot see, who cannot hear, who can't use a keyboard? So a lot of the work that they produced ends up being a factor in our daily lives. Siri and Alexa can recognize your voice because of technology that was originally designed for people who need to be able to address a computer in that way. There is a program that let the record show, I will never use, that allows your email to be read back to you while you're driving your car. That again comes from the kind of technology that was developed by people working on electronic curb cuts. What was originally thought of as something just
使计算机信息对那些看不见、听不见、不能使用键盘的人可用？所以他们产生的大量工作最终成为了我们日常生活中的一个因素。Siri和Alexa能够识别你的声音，是因为最初为需要以这种方式操作计算机的人设计的技术。有一个程序，记录在案，我永远不会使用，它允许你的电子邮件在你开车时读给你听。这再次来自于那些致力于电子路缘坡的人开发的某种技术。最初被认为只是
for people in wheelchairs ended up being just taken for granted by everybody and used in ways that weren't even originally anticipated for the benefit of many, many more people than originally thought of. And that's true for the things that we do to make the electronic environment accessible also. So now that universal design and the curb cut effect is a pretty widely held, you know, uncontroversial opinion of how design should be done. Well, where are we in
为坐轮椅的人准备的东西，最终被所有人视为理所当然，并以最初未曾预料到的方式使用，造福了比最初想象的更多的人。这对我们为使电子环境可访问而做的事情也是如此。所以现在，通用设计和路缘坡效应是一个相当普遍的、没有争议的关于应该如何进行设计的观点。那么，我们现在处于
the state of design in the built world or the electronic world? Well, I would sort of sum that up world or the electronic world? Well, I would sort of sum that up in my own experience of learning about this by describing a little bit about my time with Debbie Kaplan. At the time that we were meeting with each other, Debbie lived just outside Washington DC. And spending an hour with Debbie Kaplan is like a crash course in the advances and ongoing challenges of disability fixes,
建筑世界或电子世界的设计状态如何？嗯，我会通过描述一点我和黛比·卡普兰在一起的时间，来总结我在学习这个过程中的个人经历。在我们见面的时候，黛比住在华盛顿特区外。和黛比·卡普兰待一个小时就像是关于残障改进的进展和持续挑战的速成课程，
at least in the United States. And we are more advanced than most societies in this regard. So Debbie's an attorney. She's actually an old friend. My husband and I have known her for many years. She has a very interesting job working on electronic curb cuts and information design. She lives in a community that has been designed with universal design principles, accessible to everybody. She has a handy power wheelchair
至少在美国是这样。在这方面，我们比大多数社会更先进。所以黛比是一名律师。她实际上是一位老朋友。我和我丈夫认识她很多年了。她有一份非常有趣的工作，致力于电子路缘坡和信息设计。她住在一个按照通用设计原则设计的社区，对每个人都可访问。她有一辆方便的电动轮椅，
that gets her everywhere she needs to go. We were there in the winter. So you go down and then I successful elevator with Debbie and you go out in the street and it's tough. There are curb cuts in Silver Spring, but there's also snow on the sidewalk. There's people who left their bicycles on the sidewalk. Now here, where we are in the Bay Area,
可以带她去任何她需要去的地方。我们在冬天去那里。所以你走下去，然后和黛比一起乘坐无障碍电梯，你走到街上，这很艰难。银泉市（Silver Spring）有路缘坡，但人行道上也有雪。有人把自行车留在人行道上。现在在这里，我们在湾区，
there's people leaving these new scooters all over the place. Every time I see a scooter now, I think of people in wheelchairs, right? There was snow and I said, I turned to Debbie at one point and said, well, do they make an extra effort to come and clear the snow for people who are in wheelchairs, right? There was snow and I said, I turned to Debbie at one point and said, well, do they make an extra effort to come and clear the snow for people who are in wheelchairs who can't just dart around it the way somebody on foot can? And she looked at me and just burst out laughing and said, are you joking? So we've come a very long way and I think anybody who is presently or about to be grappling with disability will
有人把这些新滑板车到处乱放。每次我现在看到滑板车，我就会想到坐轮椅的人，对吧？当时有雪，我转头对黛比说：“嗯，他们是否会做出额外的努力来为坐轮椅的人清理积雪，因为他们不能像步行的人那样绕过它？”她看着我，大笑起来说：“你在开玩笑吗？”所以我们已经走了很长一段路，我认为任何目前正在或即将与残疾作斗争的人都会
understand how long away we still have to go. Yeah. And it's not just about universal design principles in the making of things. We have to incorporate that in just our behavior and our sense of courtesy towards one another. Precisely. Precisely. Thank you so much. Thank you. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Cynthia Gourney, edited and guest hosted by Delaney Hall. Mixed in Tech Production by Shrvee Siff, Music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kirk Colstad is the digital director.
明白我们还有多长的路要走。是的。这不仅仅是关于制造事物时的通用设计原则。我们必须将其融入到我们的行为和我们彼此之间的礼貌感中。完全正确。完全正确。非常感谢。谢谢。本周的《99% Invisible》由辛西娅·古尼（Cynthia Gourney）制作，德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）编辑并担任客座主持。技术制作由Shrvee Siff负责，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）创作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的高级制作人，柯克·科尔斯塔德（Kirk Colstad）是数字总监。
The rest of the team includes Avery Traffinman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taryn Mezza, and me, Roman Mars. Please put your hands together for the newest members of 99PI, Joe Rosenberg, and Vivian Lee. Joe did the brilliant piece on the Mojave phone booth that we broadcast a couple years ago, and Vivian reported the crazy history of weaponizing weather and that mini story on alarm design. They've both joined us full time, so if you're walking around downtown Oakland, you see them. Say hi.
团队的其他成员包括艾弗里·特拉芬曼（Avery Traffinman）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、塔林·梅扎（Taryn Mezza）和我，罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。请为99PI的最新成员乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）和薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）鼓掌。乔制作了我们几年前播出的关于莫哈韦电话亭的精彩片段，薇薇安报道了武器化天气的疯狂历史以及关于警报设计的小故事。他们都全职加入了我们，所以如果你在奥克兰市中心走动，看到他们，打个招呼吧。
Special thanks to Asada Iman for the audio from the documentary, we shall not be moved the 504 sit-in for disability rights. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% Invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm.
特别感谢阿萨达·伊曼（Asada Iman）为纪录片《我们不会被移动：504残疾人权利静坐示威》（We Shall Not Be Moved: The 504 Sit-in for Disability Rights）提供的音频。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的Radio Row制作。《99% Invisible》是PRX旗下RadioTopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet, challenge, coin news to me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you're thinking, I need more 99PI in my life. We have all the old episodes, including the first episodes by Joe and Vivian there, and new articles about design every couple of days on our beautiful, beautiful website. It's 99PI.org. Radyo Tepi from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上向我（@romanmars）和节目（@99pi.org）发送挑战或新闻。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但如果你在想，“我的生活中需要更多的99PI”，我们有所有的旧剧集，包括乔和薇薇安的第一集，并且每隔几天就会在我们美丽、美丽的网站上发布关于设计的新文章。网址是99PI.org。RadioTopia from PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。